[Music]
Fast Shield Second Shield
Dorit Shield 4 Plus Aura 3
Raphtalia Terror
Yes, it's canceled
[Music]
Donriki has
canceled the support magic [Music] Dezu
Shield Prize Gun
[Music] Nada
saved my life,
but what's next  I don't know.
[Music]
It's okay. If you
think about it, you're the owner of a descendant from a destroyed world. I don't know if you're
still alive,
but I don't think you'll be able to win like this world to the point where you can help me. You're too
weak, and it's okay to let down your expectations.
We are weak.
[Music]
You suddenly became so quick.
When you canceled your support magic, you
also lifted the curse on me.
[Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
1  Those who have withdrawn
[music]
[applause]
are Y